do you think AGI could be achieved with
a neural network as we understand them
today yes
I'll just flatly last yes the question
is whether the current architecture of
stacking more Transformer layers which
probably know gpt4 is no longer doing
because they're not telling us the
architecture which is a correct decision
oh correct decision I had a conversation
with Sam Altman will return to this
topic a few times
he turned the question to me
of how open should open AI be about gpt4
would you open source the code he asked
me
because I provided as criticism saying
that while I do appreciate transparency
open AI could be more open
and he says we struggle with this
question what would you do change their
name to closed Ai and like
cell gpt4 to business back-end
applications that don't expose it
to Consumers and Venture capitalists and
create a ton of hype and like pour a
bunch of new funding into the area but
too late now but don't you think others
would do it
eventually you shouldn't do it first
like if if you already have giant
nuclear stockpiles don't build more
if some other country starts building a
larger nuclear stockpile then sure build
then you know
even then maybe just have enough nukes
you know there's a these things are not
quite like nuclear weapons they spit out
gold until they get large enough and
then ignite the atmosphere and kill
everybody
um
and there is something to be said for
not destroying the world with your own
hands even if you can't stop somebody
else from doing it
but but open sourcing it now that that's
just sure catastrophe oh the whole
notion of open sourcing this was always
the wrong approach the wrong ideal there
are there are places in the world where
open source is a noble ideal and
building stuff you don't understand that
is difficult to control that where if
you could align it it would take time
you'd have to spend a bunch of time
doing it that is that is not a place for
open source because then you just have
like powerful things that just like go
straight out the gate without anybody
having had the time to have them not
kill everyone